la vie devant vous documentaire réalisé
par Frédéric Lafon et co-écrit avec la
journaliste Ariane chemin l'histoire
souvent méconnue de ces jeunes marocains
recrutés dans les années 60 et 70 pour
venir travailler pour le compte des
Charbonnages de France et ici vous venez
de le voir nulle regrets nul nostalgique
chez ses désormais retraités mais
beaucoup de fierté avec la certitude
d'avoir apporté leur pierre à l'histoire
récente de notre pays quel regard porté
aujourd'hui sur cette main d'oeuvre
venue des anciennes colonies françaises
et bien nous allons en débattre
maintenant sur ce plateau de débat doc
en compagnie de nos invités avec vous
pour commencer Mariam tiganimine
bienvenue vous êtes sociologue au
laboratoire interdisciplinaire pour la
sociologie économique nous vous avons vu
dans ce film au sein de votre famille au
côté de votre père dont vous avez par
ailleurs raconté le parcours ce livre
intitulé notre histoire de France
publiée aux éditions Stock c'est un
livre qui est sorti après le
documentaire que nous venons de voir et
vous avez amplement participé à
l'écriture de ce film bien évidemment on
va y revenir tout de suite on va y
revenir avec vous une beri bienvenue
vous êtes historienne chercheuse
associée à l'unité de recherche
migration et société de l'université
Côte d'Azur et spécialiste de l'histoire
culturelle des maghrébins en France vous
avez entre autres participez aux travaux
de la commission Stora consacrée aux
questions mémorielles portant sur la
colonisation et la guerre d'Algérie puis
j'ajouterai que votre père et lui aussi
venu travailler en France votre père
venu d'Algérie cette fois et non du
Maroc c'était en 1963 vous avez
d'ailleurs parti passer une partie de
votre vie à Tourcoing auprès de votre
famille on aura l'occasion aussi
j'imagine de revenir sur le parcours de
votre père et de votre famille au regard
du film que
[Musique]
c'est vrai que moi je quand j'ai
commencé à quelques années mes études de
sociologie
notamment lors d'un cours de sociologie
du travail je me suis aperçu que je
connaissais pas grand chose en fait de
la vie professionnelle de mes parents ni
de leur histoire migratoire il m'a
semblé intéressant voilà de commencer
d'abord par cette quête personnelle vous
allez jusqu'à dire j'ignorais que je
venais d'un milieu pauvres et d'un
milieu ouvrier oui ça veut dire que vous
en aviez pas parlé au sein de la famille
de ça non parce qu'en fait on vivait
donc à Mantes-la-Jolie au sein du
quartier du Val Fourré où il y a une
certaine homogénéité ethnique sociale et
c'est vrai que moi je je raconte que
voilà j'ai vécu une enfance heureuse
loin en fait des de d'un certain nombre
de problématiques liées ouais à ces
questions de de comment se définir
socialement jusqu'à en fait avoir 18 ans
prendre le train pour aller à Paris
faire des études supérieures et
m'apercevoir en fait que effectivement
selon l'Institut national de l'étude
statistique en fait
je suis en bas de l'échelle quoi et il a
fallu me confronter en fait à d'autres
univers des personnes
issues d'autres mondes sociaux pour
m'apercevoir que voilà j'avais une
histoire qui était particulière mais qui
en même temps en fait s'inscrivait dans
une histoire beaucoup plus grande une
histoire en fait des migrations en
France et une histoire en fait des
mondes ouvriers et qui était
malheureusement une histoire qui était
peu documentée vous êtes reconnu dans le
témoignage de ces anciens
dans ce qui est dit dans ce documentaire
dans ce qui est décrit dans le parcours
de vos aïeux finalement dans ce
documentaire alors comme beaucoup
d'enfants d'immigrés je pense que
l'empathie est au rendez-vous ce film
est à plusieurs niveaux
identiques à ce que mes parents ont pu
vivre en tant qu'immigré même s'ils
étaient algériens ils étaient dans une
autre industrie qui était celle du
textile ils étaient dans la même région
celle du Nord de la France une région
pauvre une région d'immigrés
et moi je viens pas comme Mariam
peut-être en un témoigné des grands
ensembles d'Île-de-France j'ai grandi
dans ces maisons ouvrières du Nord de la
France et c'est vrai que
elle apporte du film et c'est pour ça
qu'il me touche c'est qu'on entend la
parole des immigrés eux-mêmes on ne
parle pas seulement deux il s'exprime et
le récit vient des principaux concernés
et je pense c'est le principal apporte
du film c'est que la narration ne se
fait par ceux qui ont vécu cette
histoire avec le truchement de la
transmission père-fille qui est très
touchante elle se fait en 2023 c'est
aujourd'hui qu'il parle votre père il
avait des difficultés à en parler de ce
parcours et mon père n'a pas pu avoir ce
récit aussi j'allais dire aussi ouvert
aussi sincère sur son parcours mais il
fait partie de cette génération
silencieuse et cette demande de récit
qui est portée par Maria mais toute une
génération c'est celle de dire qu'on a
besoin de ce récit cette identité
narrative pour comprendre pourquoi nous
sommes français aujourd'hui et je pense
que ce film apporte cette pierre à
l'édifice de se construire ses français
d'aujourd'hui et de demain et de les
inscrire dans un une filiation celle de
l'histoire de l'immigration mais avec
une transmission du récit pour ses papas
et ses mamans qui commencent à
disparaître et je pense que c'est un
beau cadeau que nous fait Maria mais et
rien ne chemin et le réalisateur parce
que
à plusieurs niveaux il comble un angle
mort du récit de l'immigration
avec un sujet qui a à la fois universel
qui me parle alors que je suis pas du
tout d'origine marocaine ni berbère du
sud du Maroc mais pourtant c'est la même
trajectoire un besoin de main d'oeuvre
une immigration massive et aussi un
discours de retour inexorable qui ne
sait pas fait parce que l'immigration
n'est jamais rentrée chez elle Pascal
Blanchard alors c'est vrai on est en
plein cœur des des trentes glorieuses on
a besoin de main d'oeuvre
et c'est aussi les
inglorieuse de l'immigration en France
pour recontextualiser ce qu'on vient de
voir dans ce film tout à fait on est
dans un moment de c'est plus la
reconstruction du début c'est le moment
où on va basculer vers une nécessité
urbaine une demande d'emploi je rappelle
que pour aujourd'hui ce qui nous
écoutent il n'y a pas de chômage à
l'époque donc au contraire une énorme
besoin de main d'oeuvre que malgré la
fin de l'empire colonial français la
France a pris la pratique depuis très
longtemps de faire venir des
travailleurs issus de son empire
colonial français et donc elle va
continuer à la fois vers le Maghreb puis
progressivement vers la frite noire mais
aussi vers les Antilles à faire venir en
fin de compte des ouvriers pour les
différents éléments on vient de parler
du textile on parle du bâtiment il faut
aussi imaginer toute la parole pour les
ultramarins c'était la fonction publique
le monde hospitalier et en fait on va
garder un principe qui a été mis en
place progressivement en 20e siècle
d'aller recruter de manière massive dans
certaines régions avec des typologies on
a connu ça aussi avec l'est de l'Europe
les Polonais par exemple dans les années
20 30 et en fait ce mécanisme d'aller
recruter d'aller sur place chercher les
populations va être un des grands
mécanismes étranglorieuses où l'afflux
de travailleurs immigré va être
pratiquement constant tout au long de
cette glorieuse et cette main d'oeuvre
poste coloniale va peu à peu prendre la
place et être supérieur à la main
d'oeuvre immigrée qu'on connaissait
auparavant c'est-à-dire les Polonais
notamment entre deux guerres et bien sûr
les Italiens les Espagnols les Portugais
pas les Portugais qui arrivent à peu
près dans la même concomitance
temporelle et pas pour occuper les mêmes
emplois par contre pour toujours que les
immigrations succèdent ça n'arrive
jamais comme ça elle se superposent elle
se superposent et puis vous avez la
deuxième génération qui vient se
superposer la nouvelle génération qui
arrive par contre c'est beaucoup plus
complexe on pourrait pratiquement faire
un schéma où on voit comme dans un
planning les choses qui se superposent
et on voit certes arriver ces
travailleurs on les voit aussi
s'installer on voit les familles après
qui arriveront puis après il y aura la
génération le processus en fait est très
semblable à ce qu'on l'a connu depuis le
début du siècle et ça s'installe dans
des territoires qui sont demandeurs pour
des spécificités avant que les gens
aillent s'installer dans d'autres et toi
et généralement les grands ensembles que
ces mêmes ouvriers ont construit c'est
là où on comprend comment toutes les
trentes glorieuses vont fabriquer d'une
certaine manière la France aujourd'hui
peut-être vous interrogiez vous sur la
forme de discrimination
d'exploitation de temps aurait fait
l'objet de votre père avec notamment ce
fameux tampon vert lorsqu'on est recruté
pour aller travailler dans les mines en
France et le tampon rouge lorsqu'on
restera sur place et qu'on sera pas
recruté ces travailleurs marocains dont
votre père ont-ils fait l'objet de
discrimination particulière à ce qu'on
peut le dire comme ça aujourd'hui oui
effectivement c'est même documenté et
pour rebondir un peu sur ce que vient
dire parce qu'elle Blanchard faut quand
même rappeler que ces Marocains on les
fait venir pour fermer les mines eux ne
le savent pas mais en fait on les fait
venir eux particulièrement pour donc
opérer cette tâche là de fermer les
mines ensuite de repartir il avait
absolument pas vocation à rester et on
les fait venir avec un contrat spécial
et d'ailleurs tout est fait pour qu'il
ne reste pas exactement la plupart du
temps en fait ils viennent seuls c'est
des hommes célibataires beaucoup ne sont
même pas majeurs mon père par exemple
était mineur et on a menti sur son âge
en fait pour qu'il puisse venir et donc
le processus de recrutement est assez
assez particulier donc on les met torse
nu on les regroupe en fait donc il y a
un crieur qui passe de village en
village pour annoncer la venue d'un
recruteur et donc il y en a un des plus
charismatiques qui s'appelle Félix Mora
qui a un ancien militaire de l'armée
coloniale qui est là donc pour venir
palper les muscles
serrer des mains donc certains
d'ailleurs même dans le documentaire
pensait que il s'agissait d'une
salutation mais en fait il regardait si
c'était des travailleurs s'il y avait
des durillons en fait au niveau de leurs
mains et effectivement quand on était
élu entre guillemets on avait droit à un
tampon vert à poser sur son torse et
quand on était un d'année on avait un
tampon rouge et en fait je prends
justement cette expression ces
expressions des lieux de l'année parce
que c'était un peu la honte de revenir
au village sans se passe droit je
reviens cette question de la
discrimination il y a-t-il une réelle
discrimination concernant ces
travailleurs post coloniaux si on les
compare par exemple avec les immigrés
italiens espagnols et polonais qu'on a
évoqué à l'instant avec Pascal Blanchard
je pense que le feu
oui mais que des discriminations d'ordre
racistes ou dans l'espace public qui
sont une réalité j'allais dire qui
traverse l'immigrations nord-africaines
à l'époque mais bien à différents
niveaux notamment du point de vue du
droit du travail et le statut de mineur
et tous les avantages sociaux qui les
accompagnent les combats auront été
menées jusqu'à la fin des houilleurs
jusqu'à la fin des années 80 avec un
certain nombre de combats qui vont même
être postérieurs à la fermeture
concernant des statues de mineurs des
refus de retour forcés au pays également
la question de certains acquis
concernant le logement et ce qu'on
appelle les droits en nature et donc il
y a des mouvements sociaux qui vont être
émaillés des grèves et des mobilisations
dans l'Est et dans le Nord
qui vont notamment être accompagnés par
une structure associative qui s'appelle
l'ATMF qui existe toujours aujourd'hui
l'association des travailleurs marocains
de France qui va avec des alliés comme
l'appareil
syndicale de la CGT et d'autres alliés
de circonstances accompagnés
juridiquement ces travailleurs immigrés
qu'on pensait inoffensif parce que
analphabètes d'extraction paysanne très
loin
d'avoir reçu une instruction et surtout
et je pense que Marine le rappelle il y
a une question de du lien avec le pays
d'origine entre guillemets qui est
complice de cette mise au banc de la Vie
ouvrière et des droits qui les
accompagnent
c'est incroyable d'ailleurs de constater
que la rupture que l'on pense avec le
temps de la fin des colonies n'existe
pas du tout dans la relation bilatérale
et on revoit ce qu'on vient de se
raconter pour la réalisation du Sénégal
pour la revanche sur la Guadeloupe la
Martinique l'Algérie la Tunisie en fin
de compte la pratique le fait et ça
intéresse les deux états parce que d'un
côté ça envoie de l'argent
potentiellement au pays et ça permet
d'avoir une jeunesse qui pourrait se
révolter qui fait autre chose donc il y
a un rapport qui intéresse les ex
colonies et en même temps s'intéresse
parfaitement la France et notamment le
grand capital et les entreprises puisque
vous avez des gens qui un peu par le
Français pas forcément très bien mais un
peu par le français donc on se dit c'est
mieux on est sûr qu'à la fin la
fermeture des mines on va pouvoir les
renvoyer chez eux donc il n'y a pas de
risque social on ne voit pas héberger
les femmes on leur donne pas les mêmes
droits ils n'ont pas les mêmes droits
syndicaux et aussi cette perception qui
existe depuis le début du siècle j'avais
oublié que les premiers travailleurs
algériens recrutaient qui arriveront à
Marseille avant la guerre 14-18 on les
fait venir pour casser les grèves des
Italiens imaginez l'état d'esprit c'est
de se dire ce seront des hommes que l'on
pourra contrôler contrôler leur destin
contre leur circulation contre les leur
retour donc en fin de compte la rupture
entre le temps colonial et le temps
post-colonial n'existe pas dans la
notion de main d'oeuvre ce qu'on a
beaucoup de mal à comprendre aujourd'hui
c'est que d'abord et puis on l'a dit on
ne pensait pas du tout que ces individu
allait rester toute la logique du temps
c'est qu'on va les exploiter pendant un
temps court et qu'après donc tout le
monde y trouverait son intérêt y compris
eux-mêmes d'ailleurs on l'a perception
du grand capital à l'époque puis on les
renverrait chez eux l'histoire n'est
jamais celle qu'on écrit au départ et en
fin de compte c'est une histoire
celle-là qui n'est pas très visible
d'abord parce qu'on a pas jamais donné
la parole à ceux qui étaient ceux qui
ont fait cette histoire donc c'est pour
ça que le film est excellent Naïma a
raison de le rappeler c'est important
d'écouter la parole de ceux qu'on vécu
cette histoire et c'est maintenant qu'il
faut le récolter deuxièmement c'est une
histoire qui est invisible derrière la
grande histoire on oublie toujours ce
qu'on construit en route nos ponts nos
immeubles qui font nos gros ensembles
aujourd'hui et puis c'est une histoire
qui se passe à un moment on pense qu'il
y a plus de récit c'est après les
colonies et c'est pas avant les grands
débats de l'immigration des années 80-90
et pourtant dans ce laps de temps
essentiel de la fin de l'Empire et du
moment de la deuxième génération en fait
du début des années 80
se construit la France aujourd'hui se
construit une sociologie de la France
aujourd'hui et un moment qui va digérer
et avec en plus des fonctionnaires dont
ce monsieur qui va aller recruter qui
sont eux-mêmes soit issus de l'armée
coloniale soit issus de l'administration
coloniale les gens oublient toujours
qu'il a fallu faire un jour revenir les
fonctionnaires des colonies et que les
fourchettes dans les colis ils ont bien
fait un métier et qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
fait comme métier il s'occupaient de la
manœuvre ils sont occupés des foyers ils
sont occupés des grands ensembles et
donc ils ont gardé eux-mêmes une
pratique qu'ils avaient aux colonies et
donc c'est là qu'on comprend le passage
qu'il y a eu et quand vous parliez de
discrimination tout à l'heure celles qui
est peut-être la plus je m'interrogeais
de discriminer la question elle est très
pointue et que le respect c'est
travailleurs il s'était face à des gens
qui avaient d'abord eu une pratique en
colonie et qui continuait à penser ses
ouvriers comme on les pensait au
colonies et on pense qu'il y a une
rupture entre là-bas ici mais enfin
quand il y a jamais eu de rupture il y a
un va-et-vient permanent de pratique
d'habitude de perception de regards
posés et toutes ces questions là en fait
c'est dans les années 60-70 jusqu'aux
années 80 que tout ça va être la matrice
qui va venir s'installer en France qui
va construire un regard qui va faire
pareil qu'on va pas dire des immigrants
on va dire des travailleurs immigrés
d'ailleurs l'imaginaire ils sont d'abord
travailleurs certes immigrés mais quand
vous dit travailleur immigré vous pensez
tout de suite à des gens qui viennent
notamment d'Afrique donc toutes ces
constructions sociologiques toute cette
imaginaire sans qu'ils aient pu prendre
la parole et raconter leur histoire va
se fabriquer à ce moment-là ce qui est
aussi intéressant c'est que justement
vous parliez de cet échange que j'ai pu
avoir avec mon père parce que
effectivement on découvre en cette
histoire on découvrant le la manière
dont il a été recruté en découvrant les
propos d'une historienne qui qualifiait
le recruteur de négrier moi j'étais
atterré et mon père me regarde il me dit
mais tu es pas contente d'être ici et ce
qui est intéressant en fait c'est que et
vous dites d'ailleurs il m'a cloué le
bec mon père exactement il m'a cloué le
bec et en fait je me suis juste aperçu
un moment donné que en fait
effectivement il y a eu une exploitation
mon père a toujours été un perdant du
capitalisme mais en fait forcer de
constater qu'il a quand même connu une
mobilité sociale ascendante parce que
quand on regarde en fait le sort de ses
cousins de ses frères
français au pays lui voilà son t'es pas
contente d'être ici effectivement il
voit en fait le le présent de ses
enfants de ses petits-enfants et son
accès mon père me dit moi je voilà le
travail était dur oui j'ai été exploité
mais je vis dans un pays en fait où je
suis libre où il y a la sécurité sociale
et ça pour moi voilà ça n'a pas de prix
sur cet aspect ce que le témoignage de
Mariam est intéressant aussi parce que
il y a une demande de la génération des
enfants et des petits enfants de justice
de relire cette histoire à l'aune de nos
valeurs et de ce qu'on considère comme
la dignité des êtres humains et c'est
vrai que quand on entend les acteurs de
cette histoire on se rend compte que ok
il subit un régime discriminatoire
chosifiant le corps des hommes comme une
masse qu'on peut déplacer et renvoyer
dans le pays d'origine comme machine
outil mais ils sont conscients de cette
enjeu là et le dépasse parce qu'il mis
sur la génération d'après c'est le cas
de Marianne et des enfants d'immigrés en
général et c'est aussi pour ça que c'est
important de les entendre parce que
sinon en attendant de manière
anachronique à en faire des victimes
passives et silencieuses et on oublie
que c'est qu'on a dans ce document mais
grâce à la position du témoin et ça
c'est nouveau absolument parce qu'on a
beaucoup fait de récits et Pascal et moi
on appartient cette génération de
chercheurs qui avons produit des
supports parce qu'elle a signé beaucoup
de films où il met en scène ces
questions là mais la nouveauté c'est que
il y a des films d'auteurs portés par
des héritiers de l'immigration qui vont
chercher cette parole là et qui
permettent de d'élargir le panel des
experts que nous sommes pour donner une
incarnation et aussi entendre la partie
concernée cette cette ligne statistique
du travailleur immigré va s'incarner et
va donner son point de vue et ça c'est
important dans le dans le film qu'on
nous a présenté ce soir on va donner
quelques quelques chiffres pour
illustrer tout de même ce qui était
l'ampleur de cette immigration
post-coloniale
les Algériens passent de 350 000
individus en France et travailleurs en
62 à 71175 les Marocains de 33000 hommes
à 260 000 et les Tunisiens de 27000 à
140 000 74 c'est fini on a plus besoin
de main d'oeuvre
de Valéry Giscard d'Estaing s'ouvre en
arrêtant tout à fait recrutement de main
d'oeuvre parce que le mien disons que la
main d'oeuvre continue à arriver sur
d'autres manières mais globalement
l'état où on va dire les grandes
entreprises arrêtent c'est pas aussi
média que ça mais grosso modo leur
manière de la courbe descend donc on
pense qu'ils vont tous repartir bon ce
qui va pas être le cas déjà il va se
passer quelque chose au contraire on va
même leur offrir une prime rappelez-vous
le fameux million à 10000 francs à
l'époque
exactement et donc parce que c'est cette
idée que bah oui comme ils sont
corvéables mais ils vont
repartira pas bah c'est parce que les
années 70 c'est plus les années 60 et
puis qu'ils ont connu la France et puis
que certains commencent à commencé à
faire venir leur famille et puis que
certains se disent que pour l'avenir de
leurs enfants pouvoir grandir en France
c'est peut-être pas une mauvaise idée et
puis je dirais de manière ils ont
toujours été un peu français parce que
quand vous vivez dans l'empire colonial
français il y a une histoire un rapport
avec la métropole tout ça est très
compliqué tout ce dont on peut faire le
même choix certains vont repartir
d'autres vont rester d'autres vont
continuer aussi à venir parce que
certains vous le savez comme moi que
dans le regroupement vous avez aussi des
gens qui vont se dire je vais aller dans
le pays où travaille mon grand oncle ou
mon père donc vous voyez c'est un peu
plus complexe que de penser que c'est
une rupture mais oui
c'est 1976 exactement et il va se faire
progressivement sur à peu près une bonne
décennie où les familles vont venir
rejoindre ceux qui décident de rester et
là on rentre dans une autre
configuration de l'histoire de
l'immigration un autre temple c'est le
même moment où les enfants arrivent ce
n'était pas le cas avant donc on va
commencer à regarder très différemment
ces personnes avant c'était des hommes
travailleurs voilà ok vas-y et puis d'un
seul coup arrive des femmes qui arrivent
des enfants qui vont aller à l'école
l'espace public change donc ils
diffusent dans les mêmes endroits déjà
parce que les familles ne vivent pas
dans les mêmes endroits que dans les
baraquements et puis quitte les
territoires parce que les mines fermes
et puis que souvent ils ont travaillé
l'industrie est en train de changer la
frange j'avais 70 c'est la révolution
totale sur nos territoires jusqu'à la
fin des années 80 tout ça va faire
naître une autre génération mais dont en
fait ils sont les porteurs si eux
n'étaient pas venus dans les années 60
n'existerait pas cette histoire des
années 70 et 80 et en fin de compte tout
ça est très peu connu par les Français
cette chronologie convient de décrire le
pourquoi il reste pourquoi il partent et
puis même je pense que vous avez dit
toutes les deux choses étaient essentiel
ils ont pas eu envie de parler parce que
c'est un petit peu compliqué tout ça
expliquer par contre vous avez fait un
choix leurs enfants et quand vous voulez
que vos enfants réussissent vous
racontez pas tout voilà c'est une règle
d'or c'est comme ça et après vous pouvez
regretter ou pas mais c'est un choix qui
en vacances très protecteur et qui est
essentiel ils ont considéré c'était une
chance pour leurs enfants et vous savez
comme moi que le sacrifice qu'on peut
faire pour ses propres enfants c'est de
se dire ils vont grandir dans un pays
front les études un peu il y a la
démocratie et à l'époque les années
70-80 l'Afrique est un continent
compliqué politiquement et donc c'est
aussi une protection démocratique donc
toutes ces questions là il faut les
réintégrer aujourd'hui et c'est vrai que
des fois je pense qu'il n'y a que du
négatif dans cette histoire avec notre
génération ben on n'a pas toujours
raison et en même temps leur donner à
eux la parole pour venir raconter
l'histoire c'est fondamental parce que
volcan il y a que même si nous on est
des bons chercheurs il y a que eux qui
peuvent nous raconter l'histoire et vous
avez prononcer le mode sacrifice pour
ceux qui parlent dans ce film c'est
aussi c'est le mot qui m'est venu à
l'esprit quand j'ai vu votre votre
parcours celui de votre famille parce
que la génération dont parle parce
qu'elle Blanchard c'est la vôtre la
vôtre vous êtes la benjamine de cette
famille six enfants dont votre frère qui
est l'aîné qu'on voit aussi dans dans ce
film votre père lui passera des mines du
Nord à l'usine Renault à Flins je crois
d'ailleurs votre frère aussi travailler
à Flins et puis là une promotion ensuite
une promotion sociale simplement ce
sacrifice et l'ascenseur l'ascenseur
social donc vous parlez tout à l'heure
vous le devez à votre père finalement
alors moi je tiens quand même à préciser
que l'ascenseur social il marche pas
toujours il a marché une erreur dans ce
film quand on est graine les diplômes de
vos
votre propre diplôme celui de vos sœurs
le parcours de votre frère on se dit
qu'il y a eu une belle et bien une
ascension sociale pour cette génération
numéro 2 oui non mais effectivement ce
qui est important de dire c'est que il y
a en fait une réalité statistique de
groupe et il y a une réalité
individuelle pour le cas de mon frère
qui est un peu plus représentatif en
fait des enfants d'immigrés et des
enfants de classe populaire en fait de
manière plus générale effectivement il a
connu la reproduction sociale mais avec
des possibilités de mobilité au sein
donc de la même entreprise automobile
Renault mais effectivement il s'est
retrouvé au même moment à la chaîne que
mon père donc au sein de la même usine
et en fait il était
ce garçon de ce qu'on appelait la
seconde g dont on attendait aussi en
fait de renouveler la la main d'oeuvre
parce qu'en fait on savait que les pères
allaient être vieillissants et elle est
partie en retraite et il fallait en fait
des bras pour pouvoir en fait occuper
les chaînes automobiles mais à un moment
donné et là c'est une histoire que je
raconte dans le livre livre ce qui est
intéressant c'est que ce soit mon père
ou mon frère en fait à un moment donné
leur agentivité c'est exprimé ils ont
fait des choix ils ont parfois en étant
conscient en fait de leur condition
professionnelle sociale
et effectivement oui c'est des vies de
sacrifices et là pour le coup je pense
que ça dépasse la question des
travailleurs maghrébins ou africains de
manière générale je pense que c'est des
histoires qu'on trouve quand on a
diffusé le film à le vardre au Musée de
la Mine ben en fait on avait des
descendants de Polonais belge
ukrainien qui était en fait ému touché
italien espagnol parce que cette
histoire c'était aussi la leur alors
votre père il était ouvrier spécialisé
ensuite
après son passage à
l'usine Renault de Flins et c'est vrai
que la grande majorité de ces
travailleurs post coloniaux étaient
ouvriers spécialisé mais très peu formé
et c'est pour ça qu'on lui utilisait
surtout dans l'industrie la métallurgie
la sidérurgie le bâtiment
est-ce qu'on peut tout de même parler
d'une ascension sociale chez les
descendants de ces hommes qui sont
arrivés travailler dans notre pays j'ai
envie de dire que l'ascension elle n'est
pas difficile dans le sens où ils
partent de tout en bas il y a les
travaux du sociologue Sayat qui
parlaient d'os à vie ils étaient
enfermés dans cette fonction et je ne
pouvait pas plein de raisons un manque
d'instruction de d'opportunités de
discrimination etc etc connaître les
formations l'accompagnement à
reconversion etc etc mais leurs enfants
eux ont reçu l'instruction que les
colonisés qu'ils étaient n'avaient pas
reçu dans des gens que je connais mieux
seulement 14% des Algériens ont reçu une
instruction à l'école en 62 donc vous
imaginez la masse salariale des
Algériens des 711 000 dont vous parlez
tout à l'heure très peu avaient été
avaient appris à lire et à écrire en
français et donc leurs enfants ne
pouvaient que s'élever socialement mais
une fois qu'on a dit ça on a rien réglé
parce que dans les années 80 90 ce qu'on
appelait les voies de garage on mettait
un point d'orgue à reproduire
cette masse laborieuse avec des CAP BEP
ont laissé aucune marge de manœuvre à
ses enfants d'immigrés qui étaient
moyens dans leur scolarité et ça
obligeait cette génération à des
parcours d'excellence pour pouvoir
s'extraire de sa condition sociale Annie
Ernaux a parlé de
d'Yvetot Mariam aujourd'hui parle des
berbères du Maroc mais ces récits de
l'intérieur de la classe ouvrière ont
des gemmélités dans le parcours mais des
spécificités et dans le cas des enfants
d'immigrés il y a la question des
imaginaires chers aux travaux de Pascal
Blanchard qui sont est-ce qu'on imagine
que ces enfants d'immigrés sont des
Français comme les autres et à ce titre
avait-il vocation dans les années 80 on
les appelait encore jeunes immigrés
alors que certains étaient Français de
naissance aujourd'hui on dit France
parfois musulman de manière impropre
parce que c'est réel ou supposé ou
Franco maghrébins franco-arabe
franco-berbère peu importe l'appellation
on est en 2023 ces questions ne sont pas
réglées et cette question de l'Ascension
bien sûr qu'on la voit physiquement on
la voit il y a des ministres il y a des
préfets il y a des proviseurs il y a des
enseignants
je pense que l'immigration malgré bien
comme les autres immigrations que Pascal
évoquaient tout à l'heure a fait a fait
son chemin dans cette intégration des
années 80 mais la spécificité c'est
qu'elle n'était pas entrée dans le récit
collectif et que cette histoire qui à la
fois ouvrière et à la fois celle de
l'immigration c'est à dire ce double
effet kiss cool c'est vraiment ça qui
pose problème dans le récit alors Pascal
Blanchard on a parlé de la première la
deuxième génération et vous dans le
journal Sud-Ouest vous avez déclaré la
troisième génération est toujours celle
qui veut régler ses comptes avec
l'histoire et je ne parle même pas de la
quatrième génération qui regarde les
films de Rachid Bouchareb et les séries
Sud Netflix et qui écoutent les rappeurs
et les artistes d'aujourd'hui elle ne
porte plus le même regard sur ce passé
la mémoire familiale n'est plus en phase
avec la mémoire collective et le
discours officiel tout à fait la
troisième génération
veut régler la dette avec l'histoire
c'est à dire qu'elle trouve acceptable
la condition souvent de leurs
grands-parents comment ils ont été
conçus et perçus à l'époque coloniale
elle veut régler et les silences et la
manière dont l'État français a réglé
l'arrivée de leurs parents c'est tout à
fait normal puisqu'ils sont français
aucune raison de pas vouloir cliquer sur
les forces et puis en plus ils veulent
être bien dans ce pays c'est l'heure
donc ils veulent régler les trois
générations alors par chance ça tombe
sur eux par malchance ça tombe sur eux
ils savent pas forcément comment faire
mais en tout cas ils savent qu'ils vont
faire surtout qu'ils sont dans un
environnement qui est très différent
l'environnement culturel raconte
maintenant ces histoires ils vont
piocher chez un rappeur piocher dans un
film piocher dans un roman ils vont lire
du Slimani ils vont lire du mabankou ils
vont regarder le monde ils voient ce qui
se passe avec Black live matter aux
États-Unis ça va ils sont connectés au
monde réussissons ou pas réussir dans
leur parcours personnel en tout cas ils
parlent avec leurs amis ils vivent très
souvent en couple mais qui sait
maintenant on épouse pas je vous
rappelle à la troisième génération
forcément quelqu'un qui vient du même
pays que ses grands-parents moins de 15%
des Français vivent avec quand ils sont
eux-mêmes issus de l'immigration mais
quelqu'un qui est issu de l'immigration
c'est la France aujourd'hui et cette
troisième génération elle a les armes
pour le faire elle était à l'école elle
a parlé avec ses camarades elle a
manifesté peut-être contre les retraites
elle a d'autres enjeux qui sont les
migrations elle ne veut plus surtout
être piégée par la matrice qui a
fabriqué le destin de leur grand-parents
voire de leurs arrières grands-parents
et le destin leur parole puis elle veut
remplir les vitres du silence puis elle
veut comprendre pourquoi papa t'as pas
parlé et maman pourquoi t'as pas raconté
ce qui est normal et souvent ils le font
peut-être trop tard donc ils vont aussi
s'emparer de la littérature ils vont
aller lire ceux qui racontent ces
histoires parce que le texte peut aussi
permettre d'avoir une histoire
collective qui est un peu sa propre
histoire individuelle et puis un moment
ils veulent être fiers de cette histoire
et pouvoir la raconter à leur propre
enfant la quatrième génération
aujourd'hui avec donc on a le débat des
retraites on a on aura bientôt le débat
sur la loi asile et migration et en fait
c'est juste
j'ai même pas les termes quoi mais en
2023 on en soit encore
avoir ce genre de de débat en fait
l'histoire se répète un petit peu et
clairement en fait cette nouvelle
génération est là pour le coup on
dépasse en fait la question de la
migration elle elle a des préoccupations
écologiques elle a des préoccupations en
fait les droits humains et je pense
qu'elle est hyper sensible à ce que en
fait la France soit et reste une terre
d'asile et une terre de droit en fait
pour toutes les personnes qui qui
arrivent quoi je vous laisse le mot de
la fin vous voulez rajouter peut-être
quelque chose ce qui vient d'être oui
alors si c'est le mot de la fin lancer
dans une analyse du fait migratoire en
France un petit mot je suis sur quelque
chose que le film soulève avec la voix
off de Maria mais de son frère c'est
qu'elle convoque des poèmes en langue
berbère dessus du Maroc en tachlaite je
crois qui raconte Félix Mora parce que
ce que ce qu'on n'a pas dit mais on
reviendra vous le dire c'est que la
postérité de cette histoire de
l'immigration chez les Berbères la
drogue dans le cas des mineurs elle
s'est faite dans la chanson populaire
elle s'est faite dans la poésie et ses
chansons et populaire et cette poésie
elle raconte exactement les
discriminations l'exil la douleur de
l'exil parfois l'espoir de l'exil et
voilà je tiens vraiment pardon à rendre
hommage à Frédéric Lafont le réalisateur
qui a insisté en fait pour qu'on mette
de la masure du Teich latte dans le
documentaire et qui est en fait à
l'origine de l'écriture de ce poème en
fait qui rythme le film donc un grand
merci à tous les trois d'avoir participé
à ce débat là vos réactions ça sera bien
sûr sur hashtag debadoc sur Twitter
merci aussi à sel massali qui comme à
l'accoutumé d'ailleurs m'a aidé à
préparer cette émission et puis moi je
vous retrouverai pour un prochain débat
doc ça sera bien sûr avec son
documentaire et son débat à très bientôt
[Musique]